-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
Well, guys, the big news here
in New York City is,
we finally got our
first real snowfall of the year.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The city got hit hard with
1.8 inches of snow.
1.8 inches.
Is that really a big deal?
I mean, I saw more white powder
in "Cocaine Bear."
You know what I'm saying?
-Oh! Whoa!
-Yeah, we only got 1.8 inches,
but every meteorologist was
outside pretending they
were braving the storm like,
"It's a blizzard
out here, Hoda!"
People playing beach volleyball
behind them.
Some political news.
Today, Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis
released his autobiography,
"The Courage to be Free."
The book is already
a number-1 bestseller,
especially in Florida,
where it's literally
the only book on the shelf.
"It's the only thing here."
In the book,
DeSantis admits that
he actually got married
at Disney World.
-Ooh!
-Seriously.
That's like finding out
Bernie Sanders got married
in Jeff Bezos' backyard.
It's like, "Come on."
And get this -- former president
Trump criticized Fox News
for promoting Ron DeSantis
"so hard and so much."
At this point,
Trump's watching Fox feels like
your friend who can't stop
looking at their ex's Instagram.
It's like,
"Oh, she never liked that.
That's interesting.
Oh, looks like she's having
real fun there.
Meanwhile, a new
court filing shows that
Fox Chairman Rupert Murdoch
admitted some of the network's
hosts endorsed false claims
about the 2020 election.
Today, Fox News promised
to focus on real issues,
then introduced
their newest host, Dilbert.
[ Light laughter, applause ]
Thank you. Got it up there?
They got it up there.
These are pretty tense times
for Fox News,
although everyone is remaining
calm by repeating this mantra.
"At least we're not CNN.
At least we're not CNN.
At least we're not CNN."
Some more news.
Following a report from
the Energy Department
that said COVID might have
come from a Chinese lab leak,
The White House announced that
there is no government consensus
on how the virus started.
It's never good when
the government's report
on a pandemic is
just the shrug emoji.
You know, it doesn't matter
if we agree on
how the pandemic started.
The important thing is, we all
agree to pretend it's over.
Well, listen to this.
I read that The White House
is giving federal agencies
30 days to remove TikTok
from all government devices.
Every government employee
was like,
"I guess I have no choice"
and gave their boss
30 days' notice.
This is devastating.
I mean, what is TikTok without
Senator Chuck Grassley?
You know what I'm saying?
Some business news.
I saw that Wendy's is going to
start selling their chili
in a can at grocery stores.
[ Groaning, laughter ]
It's perfect if you've always
thought the chili at Wendy's
was too fresh.
Under ingredients, it just says,
"Ignorance is bliss."
Hey, did you guys see this?
A man in California filed
a lawsuit claiming
that he won the $2 billion
Powerball lottery,
but the ticket was
stolen from him.
Then a million Americans
were like,
"Yeah, already tried it, pal.
I mean, come on."
And he was like, "Yeah, I also
lost a bag of diamonds, too."
Yeah.
Experts say his odds of
winning the lawsuit are
300 million-to-1.
Well, guys, today is
the last day of February,
so I thought it would be nice to
give a little recap
of the entire month.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ February came and went ♪
♪ The shortest month,
but I feel spent ♪
♪ 28 days gone so soon ♪
♪ Kind of like... ♪
-The Chinese spy balloon.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Grammys, BAFTAs, Oscar noms ♪
♪ "Top Gun" did it,
good for Tom ♪
♪ Whether or not you win
that bling ♪
-♪ Angela Bassett
did the thing ♪
-♪ Super Bowl won
by the Chiefs ♪
♪ Eagles fans were
filled with grief ♪
♪ Rihanna's halftime
we were lovin' ♪
♪ She did it with a... ♪
-Bun in the oven.
-♪ Biden gave his big address ♪
♪ State of the Union
in Congress ♪
♪ Republicans shouted
from their chairs ♪
♪ Angrier than a... ♪
-Cocaine bear.
-♪ Valentine's did not
go great ♪
♪ You got stood up
by your date ♪
♪ Tinder tells you that
you should think about... ♪
-Retiring for good.
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Marvel's "Quantumania" ♪
♪ "Last of Us,"
"Outer Banks-ia" ♪
♪ We watched them all
except our aunts ♪
♪ Who were drooling over... ♪
-♪ "Magic Mike, The Last Dance."
-♪ February, you short king ♪
♪ Here comes March,
it's time for spring ♪
♪ We'll lose money on
our brackets ♪
♪ Then get trashed on
St. Patrick's ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
And, finally, guys,
it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
-♪ "WeTweet" ♪
♪♪
♪ "WeTweet" ♪
-Alright.
Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we, as a group,
decide something that we should
post on Twitter.
I'm gonna show you five
different tweets,
and we're all gonna
vote on whether
you like each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
Do you all have them?
Alright, very good.
Yep, they're green and red.
Green is for go.
Red is for stop.
You like, green, good.
Red, you don't like it.
It's fine.
You can vote for all of them,
you can vote for none of them,
whatever you want, and we're
gonna see the results live.
Higgins, Roots,
you have clickers, too?
-Got it.
-Alright.
Whatever tweet gets the most
likes, we will tweet it out live
on the show so
that you can all like it
and WeTweet it.
-Ah!
-It's like a shared experience.
Alright, are you guys ready
for this?
[ Crowd cheering ]
Alright.
The first tweet is...
Wow. Alright, very good.
♪♪
I can already --
-Yeah.
You can tell this is a big one.
-I can already tell you.
The band didn't play.
No one cared.
Yeah, you won't even have
to vote on this one.
I think I could see the --
The votes are in.
Let's just look at the results.
[ Drumroll ]
Not gonna be good.
Yeah, that's what I felt, yeah.
You didn't like that one.
Alright, no problem. No problem.
I guess people
like FaceTiming people.
-Yeah, they love it.
-Yeah. This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
It's like, "Wait.
Am I wearing my wife's jeans?
What is this?"
"They'll stretch out
in 20 minutes."
Alright, let's see the results.
I think this one
will be better than that one.
Let's see.
Yeah, alright, a little bit.
Not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright.
-Come on.
-Again, I want
to remind everyone,
these don't necessarily
get better.
Okay.
Here we go.
The next one says...
♪♪
-Wow! That got a groan.
-Yeah, they liked that one.
-This one's gonna get high.
-People enjoy -- Yeah.
That one people enjoyed,
I think.
Very nice.
Let's see the results over here.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whoa!
-There we go!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about.
Alright, so now I know
the clickers work.
Now I know it works.
Yeah, here we go.
Next up, how about this one?
It says...
[ Laughter ]
"I can't wait!
Oh! I'm so excited!"
[ Laughs ]
Alright, here we go.
Votes are in.
Let's see the results.
I feel good on this one.
[ Drumroll ]
-Whoa!
-Boom! Boom! Boom!
-This last one says...
Alright, here we go.
Cast your votes.
I think we know
what it's gonna be.
I think it's Uber all the way,
but let's see.
I don't know. I could be wrong.
I think I know the audience.
Alright, here we go.
We're done voting?
Alright, let's see the results.
[ Drumroll ]
There you go!
The winner is four, Uber!
That's the one.
[ Dinging ]
I'm gonna post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a WeTweet, and enjoy.